en el primer día de una misión
diplomática sin precedentes las sirenas
antiaéreas sonaron en kiev según las
fuerzas ucranianas tres personas
resultaron heridas y 12 misiles o rusos
fueron derribados mientras una
delegación africana de alto nivel
comenzaba su visita Ucrania llegaron
primero a la población de bucha donde el
mundo descubrió la magnitud de los
crímenes cometidos contra la población
civil ucraniana al comienzo de la
ofensiva rusa el siguiente punto en la
agenda fue el encuentro con el
presidente
ucranianonski siendo África uno de Los
afectados con el posible término del
acuerdo de granos este estuvo sobre la
mesa también el fin de las hostilidades
sobre la base de una garantía de
seguridad para los involucrados en el
conflicto
estamos aquí para escuchar tanto el
presidente zelensky así como mañana
escucharemos el presidente Putin y lo
hacemos con profundo respeto al pueblo
de Ucrania que le hemos expresado al
presidente zelenski pero también en
reconocimiento a las propuestas que han
planteado como fórmula de paz por su
parte el mandatario ucraniano destacó el
respeto a la integridad territorial para
Cesar las hostilidades
quiero reiterar que necesitamos una paz
real y por lo tanto una retirada real de
las tropas rusas de toda nuestra tierra
independiente
este viaje ocurre en medio de la
contraofensiva que desarrollo Ucrania y
que el mandatario ruso considera un
fracaso
en esos momentos se está combatiendo
creo que las fuerzas armadas ucranianas
no tienen ninguna posibilidad allí
ninguna posibilidad al igual que en
otras zonas
Moscú ha insistido repetidamente en que
el actual ofensiva de kiev contra las
posiciones rusas no han tenido éxito por
su parte Ucrania Afirma haber liberado
un puñado de ciudades y unos 100
kilómetros cuadrados principalmente en
el frente Sur según analistas militares
los ucranianos no han lanzado aún el
grueso de sus fuerzas y siga poniendo a
prueba el frente ruso para determinar
sus puntos débiles